time's up for the preening hacks who
pretend to be journalists on television
and in the press times up for the
mainstream news media which is decayed
to become nothing more than the
communications wing of the Democrat
Party the real winner of the fake news
Awards is you guessed it it's us baby we
will analyze the surprising subtlety of
this blunt stunt and why it worked so
well then flex talks Austin Fletcher and
Phillip Wegman join the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss how and why
Democrats sold dreamers down the Rio
Grande the looming government shutdown
and why PC fanatics think white
supremacy is okay last but not least the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I'm wearing a black tuxedo today because
time is up I'm so brave
I am so courageous RNA but time really
is up for the left-wing hacks and the
mainstream media and I don't mean it's
up in that they'll go away or they'll
stop being left-wing hacks or even that
they'll stop influencing a lot of people
but the time when places like the TV
networks the New York Times Washington
Post etc when they could pretend to be
objective journalists hard-hitting
reporters just interested in the facts
that actually is over and you have
Donald Trump to thank for that after
weeks of waiting
last night President Trump finally
presented the highly anticipated fake
news Awards for months now political
analysts have wondered what the awards
will look like will it be televised will
there be a red carpet will people wear
black tuxedos and little lapel pins and
things like that Trump first announced
the awards in November but no one was
sure he was kidding or not or if this is
a real event he then announced on
January 2nd that the awards would be
presented on January 8th then on January
7th he announced that the awards would
be January 17th and then last night he
tweeted the link to a blog post on the
GOP website listing 11 news stories that
he's already criticized for being fake
oh and also the website crashed so the
it didn't even load for several minutes
the conclusion of months of persistent
trolling which really was part of years
of trolling the news media going all the
way back to the campaign was itself just
a troll I love it so so much that's it
that's all it is it's just a blog post
it is a barely functional blog post not
a speech it not even a tweeted list just
a blog post at the GOP website and you
know what happened the mainstream media
took the bait of course they did now we
should be clear this is a non-event this
is seriously this is not it didn't even
load there was no fake news awards there
was a blog post the mainstream media
could have simply ignored this but they
couldn't could they no they couldn't
because they're empty-headed kittens and
this is their catnip who covered it
everybody covered it chrissy teigen whom
i'd never heard of until last night
hosted a fake fake news awards from her
snapchat last night newsweek ran the
headline quote forget trump
fake news Awards former Obama Ethics
chief announces president's biggest lie
of 2017 the article reads a former Obama
administration ethics or is planning to
beat Donald Trump at his own game
Wednesday trolling him with the golden
Pinocchio award for his biggest lie of
the year on the night the president is
expected to announce his most dishonest
and corrupt media awards cool bro really
cool you really got him you got him Wow
if President Trump had any idea that
former Obama ethics are norm Eisen would
tweet something then he never would have
criticized the mainstream media really
good job you Wow you got him
The Washington Post fumed quote Trump's
fake news awards were a huge flop but
guys here's the thing here's the little
secret the fact that you're writing
about the fake news Awards the fact that
we're talking about the fingers worth
the fact that there are 1 million
900,000 Google results for the term fake
news Awards that means that the fake
News Awards did exactly what they were
supposed to do how do how do people I
actually don't understand how people do
not get this how they still don't
understand as for the awards themselves
CNN won the night taking home four out
of the 11 accolades you're shocked I
know for those who still haven't seen
the blog post or weren't able to load it
last night here they are quickly these
are the 11 hits former Enron adviser
Paul Krugman predicted in the New York
Times that markets would never recover
from a Trump victory the Dow Jones
you'll observe just hit yet another
record high ABC News published an
entirely fabricated story on Trump
Russia collusion sending the stock
market tumbling CNN got another story
about Trump and Russia entirely wrong
Time magazine published a totally
fabricated story about President Trump
removing the bust of Martin Luther King
from The Oval Office wopo lied about
Trump's crowd sizes at a rally in
Florida CNN lied about Trump overfeeding
Japanese pet fish CNN lied about a
meeting between Anthony spero Moochie
and Russians Newsweek lied about the
Polish first lady not shaking president
Trump's hand CNN falsely reported that
James Comey disputed Trump's claim that
he
not under investigation the New York
Times published a false story on Trump
and global warming than number 11 of
course the Russia collusion nothing
burger
to quote Van Jones there is one last
aspect of this that I'd like to point
out because nobody has really been
covering it the mainstream media aren't
the only objects of mockery from this
stunt the fake news Awards it mocks the
fake news media but it also marks award
shows precisely as we enter awards
season formerly glamorous celebrities
wearing gazillion dollar gowns receiving
gold trophies just as the fake News
Awards highlight the irrelevance of the
mainstream news media their total fall
from respectability it does the same for
Hollywood which is virtually and
literally I'll point out burn to the
ground in recent months the fake news
Awards worked because both Hollywood and
the news media have become ridiculous
and Hollywood and the news media have
become ridiculous for the same reason
they're really the same thing the
Hollywood is a bunch of people going on
television and pretending to be somebody
they're not and the the news media are
now a bunch of people going on
television pretending to be something
they're not it's a bunch of Democrat
communications advisers Democrat
propagandists pretending to be
journalists on television that's all
they are they are nothing more than that
they've traded both of those Hollywood
and mainstream press have traded their
original missions which is to entertain
on the one hand and to dogged ly pursue
the truth on the other for shallow
left-wing hackery award shows there are
no longer glamorous they're tedious
exercises in virtue signaling from
millionaires complaining that they
deserve even more millions of dollars to
pretend for a living the mainstream
media no longer respected precisely
because formerly journalistic
institutions have become nothing more
than petty propaganda centers if the
press and celebrity reactions to last
night are any indication yesterday's
fake news awards will be the first of
many because they still refuse to see
white everyone is laughing at them
alright let's bring on our panel so
we've got a great panel with us today we
have flex talks Austin Fletcher from
flex talks you've seen his YouTube
channel and Phillip Wegman from the
Washington Examiner Phillip you look
okay but I got to tell you fleck is
wearing that Jersey tank top you look
phenomenal sir
we got to get right into the news we
don't have any more time to talk about
fake news we gotta talk about real news
Democrats have sold the dreamers down
the Rio Grande
after a apparently productive meeting on
immigration open to the press we all saw
it dick Durbin alleged that Donald Trump
called Haiti a not very nice place to
live
so Durban in doing that poisoned any
possibility of Dhaka compromise why did
he do it I don't know Phillip did dick
Durban just realized that it's better
for Democrats electoral chances to keep
calling Trump a racist and if that means
that younger illegal aliens need to be
continuing resolution what as chip as
the children's health insurance with
totally right I agree with that analysis
entirely flex Austin this seems to me
final irrefutable proof as I've said for
many years that Democrats do not give a
damn about illegal aliens at all they
just want to win elections they only
pretend to care about illegal aliens
when it suits their electoral needs
should the GOP finally talk bluntly
about that cut it out with all of the
rhetoric about compassion and humanity
and these poor people and dreamers and
all the other things that we now know
Democrats do not care about at all
should we speak bluntly yeah I
absolutely agree I think it's about time
that we did because realistically the
dead
rats have always been appealing to the
left you know sense of morality and
bigger picture I think the left
especially the uninformed left that I
come in contact with it all these
protests they think they can solve
global poverty with immigrations they
think oh the dreamers oh like they came
here young they're not familiar with the
country they came from they just want a
better opportunity and that's the
narrative that's the narrative that's
the narrative and then when it actually
comes time to make something happen
they self-sabotage and would rather shut
down the government just to you know
have a better chance in 2018 so I mean I
don't I never I thought we did negotiate
with terrorists and now the Democrats
there seem to be you know getting time
with us and our negotiations and it's
not good and they do it was so offensive
about it is there are so many awful
costs of illegal immigration something
like 40% of young women who cross the
border and girls who cross the border
illegally or raped these people are
forced to live in the shadows they can't
access a lot of services obviously
there's the flip side of that which is
the illegal immigrant crime and gang
membership such as ms-13 and there are
all these really awful vicious aspects
to it for both the illegal aliens and
for the American citizens and yet they
couch it in this language of oh well
we're the ones who care about these
people we're the only moral ones and
then you find out when push comes to
shove they don't give a damn about these
people they're perfectly willing to let
them be deported or let the let there be
some stopgap measure for them because
for them what it's all about is getting
votes and and specifically if they can
rely on 80 percent of votes if amnesty
goes through and these people tend to
trend Democrat then they'll do it for
that but if the illegal aliens we're
going to vote for Republicans they would
be the first people loading up the the
deportation trains so it's really
frustrating and I hope that in this era
of Donald Trump speaking bluntly and
taking away a lot of that nonsense PC
political talk we can speak honestly
about this and say look Democrats you're
dirty rotten cynics who are using these
poor people as political cuddles and his
little pawns and we're not going to take
it anymore and as long as they signed
the pledge the the Michael Knowles show
dreamer daca compromised pledge which is
that they all get amnesty immediately as
well
as they agree to vote for Republicans
for 25 consecutive elections then that's
fine then we can form a deal and these
people get to stay I hope I hope the
Senate takes up my my suggestion moving
on to the government shutdown itself the
White House today has signaled that it
will sign a one-month stopgap measure to
fund the government until a longer
military funding deal and budget deal is
reached flex this seems to me like the
win-win reality of Trump either he's
competent and get gets good things done
or he's incompetent and the government
governs less either way that's cool with
me should Republicans fear a shutdown in
this case hope there isn't a shutdown
just because of that you know we need to
keep paying the military and if the left
is going to have this you know quid pro
quo type thing where you know amnesty
for all we're shutting it down that's
not how this should go and just to touch
on the last point you made about the
adopted people the dreamers coming over
and you know they were left wanting
their votes the people I come in contact
with the protests who are Lee know a lot
of people are Latinos for Trump a lot of
these people came here illegally because
they respect the country and love the
country so much and I mean they that's
why they tend to vote Republican
oh so adding to your last point like the
people who are coming here illegally it
makes perfect sense that you know the
Democrats want to help them as much as
they can
cuz that's potential Democratic voters
who aren't really you know American
first ever well that's their basis
criminals but you're so right of course
we should have known that these people
would trend to vote Democrat they're
criminals and that's a key aspect of the
left-wing coalition good point
Phillip is the white house breaking
ranks with Mitch McConnell and Senate
Republicans who have ooh they themselves
have signaled that they oppose the
stopgap measure or is there some
strategy that I'm missing here when it
comes to conversations between McConnell
Ryan and Trump that's definitely in flux
and it's keeping Democrats on their toes
the Democrats should be so quick to make
that hold on conclusion that somehow
they're gonna benefit because of a
shutdown yes Trump keeps changing his
mind and our daca and immigration but he
has made some pretty significant
overtures when it comes to flexibility
so I think you know if you're talking
about that Latino vote or that dreamer
they're going to see that in this CR
deal Trump just is asking for a
continuation of funding and looking for
during registration to come through see
through this yeah I I think you're right
especially if we keep hammering them in
this way if we keep using blunt language
and now that their chief communications
wing has cracked as we saw last night in
the fake news Awards I think there's a
real chance in the old days the fear was
even if we're right on the facts we're
gonna be so blown out by the press that
it doesn't really matter and we just
have to play by their rules I don't
think that's true anymore it's largely
not true anymore so let's cross our
fingers during 2016 a bunch of Trump
supporters started using the okay symbol
and 4chan decided to troll people into
thinking that the okay sign was a white
supremacist symbol so the son of New
Jersey's Democrat governor Phil Murphy
played this game he did a little circle
sign during his father's swearing-in
and so the okay sign has many innocuous
connotations obviously there's nothing
inherently racist about saying hey okay
everything's good and it there's also
this childhood game whereby you make
someone look at the little okay sign and
then if they look at it you punch them
like they did on Malcolm in the middle
you might remember this
jerk you looked Wow yeah so I used to do
that as a kid it's pretty fun and so
anyway 4chan decided to make this a
symbol of their support for Trump or
something and Media Matters immediately
pounced on this so now the New Jersey
press are calling this kid racist flex
is okay white supremacists
I'm not asking by the way if white
supremacy is okay that is a subtle
distinction is the okay sign or we can't
use that anymore it's news to me but
yeah I mean leave it to the left to ruin
everything
Pepe the Frog was like a meme a popular
meme on 4chan and reddit and then
someone made I think a Nazi version of
it and now everyone who's ever used the
Pepe the Frog name is a Nazi and it's
just leave it to the left to ruin
everything they've already ruined
Hollywood they've been ruined every you
know city that they run I just saw a
lore'l commercial I came out today for a
shampoo and the woman in the commercial
was wearing a hijab you're kidding me
that can't be true it's true that is
unbelie--
beyond parody and that's the problem we
are now beyond parody where even the
okay symbol has become this Nazi thing
or this white supremacist thing Philip
you know admitted and avowed racists
like Richard Spencer they now use the
symbol but it seems to me like it's
ironic it seems to me fortune is
trolling PC culture wearing even the
most innocuous of symbols could be
deemed offensive and the PC culture
totally took the bait
so can we can we use it or not is
someone are they gonna take a picture of
this screenshot of me doing the symbol
and now I became a Nazi is that what's
going to happen I think
comes along and starts using this as a
racist but they actually the alt-right
in they're being jerks about this kind
of underscore the same point for the
mainstream media which is that they
don't get to tell me what totally
innocuous widespread symbols mean the
mainstream media doesn't get to redefine
the okay sign or what's the next the
thumbs up or something and likewise
Richard Spencer doesn't get to do that
there are like 50 of these people in the
entire world who are actually white and
nationalists who wanted to pour it all
the black people and they don't get to
define widespread symbols for me they
they can I've got two words for those
people the mainstream media and the all
right and those words are not happy
birthday okay that's all the time we
have panel thank you for being here now
it is time we have to get to the mailbag
that is philip Wegman from the
washington examiner and flex talks go
check them out on youtube before we get
to the mailbag I'm sorry Marshall he's
cutting me off is I'm hearing they're
it's like they're playing me off like it
all the other awards shows times up for
me so if you're on Facebook and YouTube
you have to go over to Daley wire.com
right now if you're on Daley wire calm
thank you
you help keep the lights on you keep
qoph fa in my cup we really appreciate
it what do you get if you join the daily
wire well you get me you get the and
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show it's ten bucks a month or 100
dollars a year you get no ads on the
website get to ask questions the mailbag
you have to ask questions on the
conversation by the way the next version
of the conversation is going to be me so
get ready for that and ask your
questions but who cares no one really
cares about any of that stuff
what we really care about is this and
and the this the leftist here's tumblr
we now have a really wonderful vintage
you have got to get this there the Cory
Booker leftist tears and I didn't know
you never can quite tell when a vintage
batch is gonna come up but it's 2018 and
it's all thanks to Cory Booker so make
sure that you have the the right vessel
because it would be such a shame if you
collected all of Cory Booker's salty
delicious and ridiculous tears and then
they went bad and then went bad you
couldn't drink them
ten years or 15 years that would be so
it would be a real shame in a real waste
make sure you store them properly in the
leftist here's tumblr you can keep it in
a nice dry area and it will maintain the
perfect salty ratio so you can gobble up
all of Cory Booker's absurd performance
the other day okay go to daily we're
calm we'll be right back with the
mailbag
[Music]
you
[Music]
you